[Musica]
la mia vita per 24 ore
questa volta sarà leggermente diverso
perchè sarai youtube contro instagram
piano piano vedrete come of selezionato
e sparso le varie domande
comunque la prima domanda che piuttosto
è cosa volete che faccia come colazione
cosa volete che mangi per colazione e vi
ho messo le varie opzioni questo era
youtube e la maggior parte di voi tipo
costata per cento ha votato un pacchetto
è scritta ora devono porsi
una fame
[Musica]
allora può anche ottima sono usciti
orribili
ovviamente quando firmiamo il video
escono orrendi ne abbiamo fatti al
tramonto sono tutti bene ma forse sono
di più scemi abbiamo tutti anche qualche
giorno fa e sono un aereo sono usciti
orrendi lo stesso quindi sicuramente
stiamo sbagliando qualcosa con gli
ingredienti qua non come li faccio
vedere che sono terribili
ecco qua un po di frittata e omelette
questa forma qua
l'ho fatta io ora andiamo a mettere ecco
qua andiamo a mettere lo sciroppo mi
piace tantissimo lo sciroppo d'acero
buonissimo che ho messo troppo
vabbè masticava mangiare buon appetito
storie stand anche se non so che ora
sarà da un po che quando guarderete
questo video
fatemelo sapere nei commenti non male
quello dai pensavo peggio
nel prossimo poi oltre ai fatti
vediamo un po freddo e cappuccino di
soia brucia
fatemi sapere se voi avete mangiato
anche se avete tutti voi avete mangiato
sia qualche parte e se vi sono piaciuti
e oggi mangiato con lo sciroppo un po
più montella secondo me sono meglio come
sciroppo
ora mi avesse detto che volete che mi
trucchi con un trucco colorato perché su
questa volta su instagram fatto il
sondaggio e vi ho chiesto volete che
metterò che contro con entro niente o
colorato cosa se si sente lava
tradizione si fonda comunque avete
scritto troppo colorato sapere che io
non mi trucco moltissimo il fondotinta
non lo uso da anni mi trucco poco mi
metto più che altro la matita nera negli
occhi e un po di browser
quindi in realtà non è ideale come
farebbe stato il coccolato mi faccio
vedere i colori che ho a disposizione a
disposizione o questi tre colori
quindi diciamo che questo viola e questo
un po arancio il grigio sono i colori
più colorati e quindi proverò a fare una
sorta di ombretto con questi colori ma
ripeto da tanto che non mi trucco poi
elaborata mente quindi non so cosa
uscirà fuori e poi dopo
dovere anche l'out pitt che avete votato
voi poi avete puntato anche una cosa per
i capelli che per adesso di non
danneggiarvi poveri finirà male
vabbè prendo questo viola sto pennello
un po floppy un po da sfumatura lo metto
qua negli angoli degli angoli piaceva un
sacco toccarne le super appassionata di
trucchi facevo trucchi molto elaborati
poi non lo so ma ho per su paul
interesse è praticamente nessuno
dimenticate tutto mi piacerebbe imparare
a truccarmi bene cosa che si può non sa
quasi tempo poi dopo dell'iss truccarti
si vuole un sacco di tempo e poi il
fatto dalla pelle non voglio appunto che
noi facciamo nella pelle per quello che
ho smesso di usare fondotinta un fa
e infatti la mia pelle mi dia retta
tantissimo fatemi sapere se volete
saperne di più perché ho anche le foto
di com'era la mia pelle prima e come a
dirsi lo vedrete vispa va in parte
veramente atene sta bene poi se vorreste
vedere
qualche blog oltre a questi in cui
controllato la mia vita per 24 ore
bene se volete vedere qualche blog ok
nonostante abbiamo e stiamo poi il
colore viola quarti non si vede ora
avuto questo pennello piatto e metto
quella rancio ok ora vado a mettere un
po di terra abbronzante perché vi
starete chiedendo come mai se vai al
mare non s'è ancora approntata perché
non sono tantissime protezione solare
per evitare di bruciarmi e di carnagione
non solo molto scure come potete vedere
sono pienissima e penso ma sto cercando
di abbronzarmi piano piano anche se qui
ci vuole più tempo ma voglio evitare di
rovinare la pelle appunto perché seppur
delicata la mia pelle che ora mette un
po di illuminare dunque su pennello
fighissimo che mi ha inviato su gruppi
io cioè quanto fin qui sul pennello che
piatto ok ragazzi questo trucco che un
fatto mi dispiace che non sia molto
colorato come avete votato voi ma
appunto non ho moltissimi colori
comunque se un po di bay un po di
violetto insomma ora arriva la parte più
difficile mi ha chiesto come volete che
faccia i capelli lisci con le codine
legati mi sembra o con i boccoli e voi
avete votato quasi tutti boccoli quelli
ora prendo larghezza capelli e anche
quello è da anni che non lo uso speriamo
di non bruciarmi che i ragazzi ecco qua
la rezza cappelli aiuto non ha nemmeno
la clip
quindi devo stare super attenta ho paura
di bruciarmi l'orecchio allora iniziò
con una ciocca qua
tra l'altro numeri quello proprio come
si fa dovrebbe riguardare un tutorial
moto per proviamo allora se non sbaglio
si iniziano a passo e si avvolge la
zucca e si aspetta
ok provare lasciarlo vediamo se è uscito
è uscito
oddio mi è sembrato per strano vedermi
con i capelli così mossi
e chissà come escono gli altri cioè
quando li farò tutti come farò oggi è
stranissimo per me da tanto tanto tempo
che non mi vedevo con i capelli mossi
no questo tessuto molto bene per la
sfida e si stanno attrezzando che i
ragazzi
ecco il risultato allora ci ho messo
tipo mentore a farle non sono le ragazze
che se lasciamo sempre come fa un
utilizzo più di pazienza oltre che il
caldissimo comunque fatemi sapere
secondo voi come me stanno se vi
piacciono non sono super super e
definiti perché come vi ho detto non
sono super esperta io appunto vi vedo
superstrada e non lo so un po video sono
ma non so se le farei spesso insomma
diciamo vediamo anche quanto durano
durante la giornata e vi faccio vedere
anche il mio outfit che avete
giustamente scelto voi anche il mio
outfit su youtube mi ha chiesto se
volevate che mi vestirsi con un
vestitino con dei pantaloncini in chrome
top in quanto non se n'è mai e
oppure con necro top interprete scritto
ma che è un top sarebbero le magliette
quelle corte che fanno vedere un po la
panza che sono l'ideale per l'estate
perché fanno un sacco di fresco comunque
ecco il mio hobby il mio outfit o questa
magliettina gialla queste sono
pantaloncini corti e le pantofole
vabbè poi devo mettere le scarpe
ovviamente scusate se un po di casino è
stata la scatola devo fare qualche video
riguardo
comunque questa maglia gialla
l'ho comprata o fa è in realtà il giallo
era un colore che non sopportavo che non
riuscivo ad indossare invece del solo
d'oro che se voi sarà poi vi ho fatto un
sondaggio su instagram
siccome stato certo un punto delle cose
da fare oggi
io ho visto che c'è una fiera dei
videogiochi è enorme non è chiesto se
volete che vada a questa fiera dei
videogiochi e mi avete detto di sì
quindi ora mentre le scarpe prepariamoci
e andiamo la fiera di videogiochi
vediamo cosa si aspetta spero tante cose
divertenti
pronti via
c'è chi fa tantissimo e dotare i miei
capelli la prossima volta che gli pare
però mette devo mettere qualche prodotto
oppure ai capelli troppo lisci non lo so
comunque entry auguriamo che sia un po
di fresco
[Musica]
tu
torniamo
[Musica]
roma
marino queste mamme
in modo che portano
[Applauso]
e pronta
lì pronti
[Applauso]
allora
lo era
tutti
allora
si no
torino si saranno persi
picchiava
vuoi dire
l'ing
i propri cari
km giocavo da piccolo
io sono mia zona
da cannes
ora proviamo
red
[Musica]
sì
quando la terra
grazie
ragazzi stiamo uscendo
la struttura della fiera che è stato bbc
il dr era fantastico infatti vi
ringrazio per aver votato
dissi a entrambe le opzioni su instagram
ora abbiamo appena fatto quello che
bisognava sparare è però che tra un
brano visto dall'esterno sembra strano
ma quando indossi davvero lo schermo
quell'ora onofri notte ci sembra 10 ora
preoccupante comunque ora c'è un
bellissimo tramonto e devo ancora
decidere cosa mangiare per cena
guarda che bel 3 1 turno
la giusta della metà allora ho fatto il
sondaggio su instagram e gli ho chiesto
se voleva che mangiarsi sushi
vegetariano
o le volte che cucina sia casa e per il
51 per cento mi sembra avete scelto il
sushi vegetariano per un sacco mi
volevano che indossa calze cucinare
non so perché comunque sono contenta che
la tesi cento suu kyi perché siamo
stanchissimi sono le dieci e mezzo siamo
stanchissimi abbiamo anche distrutti
perché abbiamo camminato tutto il giorno
e avevo anche voglia di sushi non fa
molte luci dell'albero e niente ora sta
arrivando e vi faccio vedere come il
nome stesso perfetto che abbiamo provato
il signore buonissimo e allora ecco i
primi soci che sono arrivati ovviamente
sono vegetariani hanno riso l'avvocato
sopra cosa credere che sono meravigliosi
di meravigliosi sono moltissimi a sé che
carina la bacchetta questo ristorante
super cura altro guardate che palle
[Musica]
salutano già mangiando di nascosto e
questo ristorante si chiama occhio 8 se
venite a malaga venite a mangiare in
questo ristorante giapponese perché il
più buono in assoluto sono anche molto
gentili sono super carini e si dica
poi qualche commento se non volete
vedere un video mappe
solo di sushi degli italiani allora io
me la tempura di verdure tempura di
verdure tutto legge italiana
vediamo le zucchine rai questo che cos'è
testa ma sai che non lo so la mia mano
la patata dolce l'asparago qui dato che
l'ascom e non so cosa sia questo sembra
un mini albero torace ma non pensa prima
di darla si metterà la salsa prima
super
essendo così piccolo aspettiamo adesso
abrate e sta molto a cuore
noi proviamo la melanzana che in genere
un meraviglioso tanta tanta
[Musica]
brucia spiedini di giapponese si
chiamano cmg uscita anche mortali sono i
giapponesi sono buonissimi siamo a casa
è tardissimo sono superfunk a ora mi
strucco lavo i denti vado a fare la
doccia e guardiamo qualche video su
youtube
guardiamo sempre qualche biblici prima
di andare a dormire e poi dormiamo
mi raccomando lasciate un bel like se
volete vedere altri video come queste se
volete vedere altri blog
fatemi sapere nei commenti qual è stato
il momento che i pianti divertite di più
a me sicuramente quando fatto il dr
quello nella pedana foto fantastico
fatemi sapere tutto nei commenti e qui
mando un bacione enorme